Joe Biden lit the White House up in
rainbow colors yesterday after hosting a
ceremony with a child obsessed groomer
drag queen to sign a law that
fundamentally redefines marriage the
fundamental political unit and
effectively Outlaws The True Meaning of
Marriage understood by Christians Jews
Muslims and every even semi-reasonable
atheist and agnostic since time
immemorial from the Public Square
and somehow that was not even the
craziest part of the show the craziest
part of the whole ceremony came when Joe
Biden attempted to ground all of this
grotesquery
in the Declaration of Independence
this law matters to every single
American no matter who you are or who
you love
this shouldn't be about conservative or
liberal red or blue
no this is about realizing the promise
of the Declaration of Independence a
promise rooted in a sacred and secular
beliefs
forget marriage for a second forget for
a second the drag queens and the
groomers and the rainbow colors on the
White House
this man actually said that the promises
of the Declaration of Independence are
rooted in sacred
secular beliefs which is a contradiction
in terms because sacred and secular are
opposites sacred means connected with
God
secular means not connected with God a
thing cannot simultaneously be both
sacred and secular it can only be one or
the other and we know which one it is
when we're talking about the Declaration
the premise of the Declaration of
Independence that we all know we all can
recite by heart is we hold to these
truths to be self-evident that all men
are created equal that they are endowed
by their creator with certain
unalienable rights and among these are
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness the whole point is that we
have certain rights and those rights
come from God
no God no rights that is the premise of
the country
but Biden had to make his absurd Claim
about secular values because he knows
that this law
redefining marriage as a practical
matter is not really about redefining
marriage which already happened seven
years ago the Supreme Court
this law is about suppressing religion
it's about punishing Christians and Jews
and Muslims for practicing their
religion in public it's about banishing
God and anyone who wishes to follow God
from the Public Square
it redefines marriage but for a broader
purpose
because these radicals know that if you
redefine the fundamental unit of society
you redefine the entire political order
a Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Chris Hansen
is it is that the Chris Hansen is that
the sit right over here come on just
have a seat kind of Chris Hanson I don't
know it's amazing if he watches this
show
he says Michael should get fined 250 by
the DW every time he makes that gur
sound during Pajamagram commercials
excuse me are you referring to
because that what I talk about the the
naturally nude Nike what do you want me
to do okay I'm just I'm just expressing
what I feel and what you will feel if
you if you get the 90 okay and that will
just help make your home a wonderful
place to live in you got to protect that
home that's why you need a ring
Christmas is around the corner many of
us will be traveling to see our families
and loved ones soon you may find
yourself away from home more often than
not that is why I have teamed up with a
ring with ring security products you can
rest easy knowing that your home and
family are safe when you're not there
the ring doorbell notifies you when
guests or packages arrive Rings indoor
cameras let you keep an eye on kids and
pets while you're away ring alarm will
alert you of any motion detection while
the house is empty plus if you add smart
lighting around your home you can turn
lights on or off while you're away Rings
home security products do not just help
keep your family and your home safe they
also make perfect gifts for everyone on
your list not only have I gotten ring I
have also given ring to friends of mine
makes a great housewarming gift makes a
great great Christmas gift okay that way
that way you can rest easy knowing your
friends and family are safe head to
ring.com collections slash offers to
find out how you can live a little less
stressed this season with a ring product
that is right for you that is ring.com
collections slash offers
the respect for Marriage Act One of the
more orwellian titles for a Bill signed
at the White House in the most grotesque
ceremony the man could possibly put on
the the only thing that could have made
the show even more absurd and even more
decadent would be if Joe Biden's
gender fluid pan-trans gender nuclear
waste disposal guy showed up in his
stilettos with the lipstick with the
grown man wearing a leather doggy outfit
on a leash but that man Sam Brinton was
otherwise occupied having his mug shot
taken for stealing women's luggage and
clothing and jewelry we'll get to that
in a little bit otherwise Joe Biden
really went all the way here and he said
that this law
represents
all that is good and decent about
America
you know there's nothing more decent
more dignified more American
that we're about what we're doing here
today
it's about who we are as a nation
it's about the substance of our laws
it's about being true to the best of the
soul of America
whatever you think about the law
whatever you think about marriage
there's nothing more decent you're
telling me hold on even look you know I
oppose the law I think marriage has a
meaning and it doesn't mean what the
libs are pretending it means now but
regardless maybe you disagree with me
that's okay but you hold on you're
trying to tell me
there is nothing more decent than having
weird groomer drag queens show up at the
White House and and pretend that men are
women and women like even if you think
that's a good thing you're telling me
that between that and helping a little
old lady cross the street
that that that is more decent you're
telling me that going out and and baking
a pie
for you know the poor little old Widow
that lives in your neighborhood I don't
know why why these old women keep
cropping but you're telling me that no
no baking the pie for the the sweet
little old Widow is not more decent than
having a bunch of creepy drag queens
dancing around the White House I just
don't it's hard to say that's the most
decent most wonderful
thing to do now Biden says it's really
really decent because right now you see
gay people the LGBT community faces
terrible discrimination and and we had
to write this wrong we had to address
this Injustice
he wrote The Following
Puerto Rican said
process presidents including Griswold
Lawrence
a burgerfuel that means he thinks we
should reconsider
whether you've got the right access to
consent to cut to contraception and yes
we should reconsider whether you have
the right to marry who you love
and that's not only the challenge ahead
when a person can be married in the
morning and thrown out of a restaurant
for being gay in the afternoon this is
still raw still wrong now of course
neither of those things can happen
gay people can get married and always
could get married because marriage has a
meaning and marriage involves sexual
difference two men cannot become married
to one another they can buy a house
together they can live a life together
they can visit each other in the
hospital they can do all sorts of things
nobody begrudges people doing those
things
but they can't get married it's not
possible it's an ontological impossible
two women cannot get married to one
another that's just not what marriage
means and certainly
they cannot be thrown out of restaurants
for being gay that doesn't happen in
America
do you know what does happen in America
people get thrown out of restaurants for
being conservative
that happened to us two days ago that
the timing of this was just amazing
because I I mentioned in my all access
yesterday that the daily wire Christmas
party was two nights ago we had a
Christmas party at a a event space in
Nashville and right next to that event
space is a restaurant and a bar it's
called hathorn Restaurant and Bar
I'd eaten there a couple of times it's
one of these sort of fancy hip young
cool bougie type places but had
perfectly nice dinners there before and
so daily wire makes a reservation gets a
room at the restaurant we put a deposit
down this thing is good to go and then
we get a call
from one of the managers of the
restaurant says hey
are you are you guys the daily wire
and our assistant who was putting this
together says yeah yeah that's true
and the the guy who was managing the
restaurant he told us we couldn't come
he told us we couldn't have our
reservation and I don't have his exact
phrasing but it was something to the
effect of your company means to harm me
and my employees
we're gonna we're gonna harm him by I
don't know we're going to we're going to
read him too many Edmund Burke quotes or
something I don't know we're gonna we're
gonna harm him we're going to how are we
going to harm him I don't know he
couldn't provide an explanation for that
we the daily wire probably the most
buttoned up sort of bookish conservative
Outlet out there we're gonna harm him
somehow with what I don't know all of
our assault statistics we're gonna harm
him with all of our very dangerous
political philosophy whatever it is and
so we got booted out it wasn't just us
there was a a Christian group it was one
of the groups associated with focus on
the family went to have a dinner at a
restaurant they threw them out for being
Christian that's what really happens
that nobody in anywhere in America gets
thrown out of a restaurant for being gay
or being black or for being a Muslim or
from any of the groups that the libs
will tell you are under constant assault
and attack in America the people who get
denied public accommodation are
conservatives and Christians that's it
okay that's that's what really happens
here
and so Joe Biden signs this law to right
or wrong that isn't happening
and to to further persecute Christians
and Jews and Muslims and any ordinary
agnostic person what this law does it it
does not redefine marriage that already
happened at the Supreme Court level what
this law does is it repeals the Defense
of Marriage Act
and it it opens up Christian Jewish
Muslim any kind of business owner that
thinks that marriage has a meaning they
will now be open to lawsuits to having
their their businesses absolutely
destroyed
and and they will be destroyed we know
that this happened this is what happened
to Jack Phillips at masterpiece cake
shop this is what happened to other
businesses that ever stand up against
these radical political activists they
are targeted for years and years and
years until the business is destroyed
and now they don't have the legal
protections to stop that and it wasn't
just the Democrats who voted for it
Republicans voted for it too this bill
passed 61 to 36 so there were a bunch of
Squish lib totally spineless totally
useless Republicans people like Mitt
Romney who went along
with it
this this is how
this is how conservatism dies not with a
bang but with a whimper with a pathetic
little squishy whimper okay and you're
gonna die too someday that's why you
need epic will right now go to
epicwill.com use promo code Knowles a
will determines how your financial
assets are dispersed as well as your
personal property it ensures that your
end of life decisions are honored when
you are unable to see them through for
parents a will determines who will raise
your kids should you and your spouse die
before they are of age without a will
the state will make this decision for
you if you're just starting out and you
don't have thousands of dollars to spend
on an attorney but you want to make sure
that your savings your belongings and
your family are all protected you've got
to create your will at epicwill.com
today Epic World bundles your last will
living will Healthcare power of attorney
HIPAA release and durable Financial
power of attorney it only costs 119
bucks okay 119 bucks for a single person
to create will
and when you use promo code normals you
will get 10 off go to epicwill.com use
promo code nulls Canada
you can save 10 on Epic Wills complete
will package that is epicwill.com promo
code Knowles
the libs used to say what's it what's it
matter to you
what if someone gets married what's it
matter to you
if someone okay let's say they don't get
married let's say we just you know
fundamentally redefine what marriage is
what's it matter to you who cares what
two people do in their house
who cares well they showed us what they
think of their house
yesterday when they lit up the White
House in rainbow colors
again Obama already did it when the
Supreme Court and Anthony Kennedy the
Romantic poet from the Supreme Court
redefined marriage well they did it a
second time now
who cares who care I don't know who
cares
I mean I care I guess I care because it
this is political and I am supposed to
have some say in my government we are
notionally a self-government still
who cares what we say about marriage
well I care it's the fundamental
political institution how does it affect
you how does it affect me that you are
now broadcasting a a brand new
not only social but religious message
from the White House this is religious
this is making religious claims Joe
Biden made religious claims Joe Biden
made the claim that our rights in the
Constitution don't come from God he said
there's secular values they're
disconnected from God that is a
religious and irreligious statement is
really what it is
it's it's and
overt denial of God's role in giving us
our rights and obviously without God we
couldn't have any rights
who who gives us the rights who gives us
the law
who gives us this whole world who's the
creator he Biden doesn't answer those
questions he just says it's not God this
is so radical
what's that matter to you come on who
cares what's the what's the big deal if
we
if we issue certain Supreme Court
decisions that lead to the sexual
Revolution going all the way back to
Griswold and eisenstadt and Lawrence and
now bergafel and all the rest of them
that just find in the Constitution all
sorts of things that aren't there you
might like condoms very much show me the
right to condoms in the Constitution
show me the right to Eccentric sexual
practices in the Constitution show me
the right to or the mandate to radically
redefine marriage away from what
everyone throughout history has thought
it was it's just not there but why did
they do this sort of thing well how does
it affect you how does it affect me what
the Constitution says how does it affect
me what religion the White House is
establishing on its Portico how does it
affect me whether or not I can run a
business that that and not be forced to
participate in Acts that I consider to
be immoral and sacrilegious how does
that affect me it affects me how does it
affect me what the fundamental unit of
society is who cares who cares the left
cares dummies I'm not talking to you you
people listening understand but but the
squishes and the libs and the Mitt
Romney's don't understand how does it
affect you
who cares
the left cares that's why the left has
spent so much time and money trying to
get this done
ultimately with the acquiescence of you
squishes and Libs Mitt Romney that's why
oh who cares what pronouns we use the
libs obviously care maybe they care for
a reason who cares which bathrooms
people go into the libs obviously care
maybe they care for a reason maybe who
cares what the meaning of marriage is
the libs care maybe they care because
they recognize that words and symbols
have meaning and if you can pervert
language if you can pervert the signs
and symbols in the way that we perceive
ourselves in the world then you can
control the whole political culture if
you control the language you can control
people's minds this is of course the
thesis of my book speechless controlling
words controlling Minds number one
National bestseller will still arrive in
time for Christmas head on over to your
favorite Bookshop today make sure to
order several copies now I don't want to
leave you hopeless here with a little
bit of Hope
this law repeals the Defense of Marriage
Act just what 16 years ago Joe Biden
went on TV and he defended the Defense
of Marriage Act and he said I voted for
the Defense of Marriage Act and that's
the law of the land and we're not going
to have gay marriage and that's the end
of it
and now of course Joe Biden's making the
absolute opposite arguments and that's
because Joe Biden doesn't believe
anything and he just blows in the wind
and he's completely unprincipled and
he's a liar he's been a liar for his
whole public career more so even than
most politicians well this this should
give us a little bit of Hope
because if the Democrats can repeal the
Defense of Marriage Act
and we can repeal the so-called respect
for Marriage Act we can we can do it in
principle we should do it
the reason that we might not be able to
do it in practice is because of the libs
and the squishes and they want to
discourage us and they want to tell us
it's all lost it's not all lost the
Democrats didn't say it's all lost after
DOMA
the Democrats didn't say oh it's all we
have to give up it's the law of the land
now we got to give up no they just they
just worked consistently for 16 years to
to repeal it more than 16 years going
back to the 90s they worked to repeal it
and we can do the same thing and we
should do the same thing we shouldn't
let the libs and the squishes and the
Mitt Romney's stop us now
Whoopi Goldberg has a theory as to why
certain Republicans voted for this
radical act that Beyond whatever you
think about marriage that's almost
secondary to what this act does the ACT
prohibiting the practice of Christianity
and Judaism and Islam and reasonableness
in an important way in the Public Square
here's Whoopi's Theory as to why some
Republicans went along with it
anytime somebody decides that they want
to get married
don't tell them that they're it's like
Jim Crow laws voting for that because
you're giving the finger to lots of
married couples and I suspect many of
these folks voted the way they did
because somebody they know said if you
don't vote this way I'll never speak to
you again perhaps a lover maybe a friend
wait what do you catch that at the end
she goes yeah it's because these
Republicans people in their lives told
them that if you vote this way I'll
never speak to you again and maybe that
person's a lover
maybe these Republicans maybe they have
gay lovers secret gay lovers and their
gay lovers were going to be really upset
with them if they didn't vote for this
tihihi
so I don't I don't think look I don't
particularly care for Mitt Romney he
drives me up a wall I don't think the
guy's got a gay lover I don't think
that's why he voted for this stupid bill
okay the same with these other people
who voted for it
but this is always where the the libs go
they say if you oppose their agenda if
you if you think that drag queens
shouldn't go read stories to
kindergartners say well why is it
because you're secretly gay huh which is
kind of funny because on the one hand
the libs are saying there's not
absolutely nothing wrong with being gay
it's actually the most wonderful thing
in the world everybody should be gay and
then on the other hand they're saying
yeah what are you are you a gay like
it's an insult you know yeah if you ever
disagree this word call you gay which is
really wonderful and it's the most
wonderful thing in the world except when
you do it you gay guy you dumb gay
person you're like like they're you know
in fourth grade on the playground so
there's a little bit of a contradiction
you might even call it homophobic if you
ask me but let's just go with Whoopi for
a second
let's say that this is why certain
Republicans voted for because they all
they all have secret gay lovers
that that part is is probably not true
but everyone does have something you
know everybody's got a past everybody's
got skeletons everybody's done plenty of
bad things that they're ashamed of and a
lot of it is a sexual because man is
such a sexual being but some of it's not
sexual maybe it's a financial fraud
maybe it's uh some other kind of
political Scandal maybe it's a Family
Matter maybe it's whatever it is a good
reminder
that you should live a clean life you
should Endeavor to live the cleanest
life you can
because it's good for your soul and it
will be conducive to your salvation in
The Virtuous Society
but also because your enemies want you
to live dirty and they want you to live
dirty because it can entrap you
because they can blackmail you because
they'll have dirt on you okay this is
one of the oldest tricks in the book
in the in the darker corners of politics
Espionage a political blackmail all of
it you you have these kind of Honey Pot
operations where you try to get a guy to
cheat on his wife or you try to get a
guy to take a bribe or you try to get a
guy to just do something dirty and you
do it because that will give you an
upper hand on them and we're living in a
world right now that is defined by data
increasingly companies and governments
are just getting every
ounce of data that that you possess
they're prying it out of you without you
even knowing it they're monitoring your
eye movements on your phone to see what
you're looking at when you're scrolling
up and down social media apps I think
this is in large part why the
instant powerful institutions in our
culture are pushing pornography on
people I think it's because it
compromises people I think it's because
it gives everyone such a sense of Shame
and fear and blackmail that that they
they just acquiesce it gives
the people
who are in power even more power it's no
different than J Edgar Hoover running
the FBI getting dirt and compromise on
people it's no different than the KGB
getting compromise on people and so you
you've got to be aware of that just in
your personal life this is how they
think
they think yeah well we're going to tell
people about your gay lover yeah we're
going to tell people that all your dirty
habits yeah if you don't go along with
us it is what it has always been
a method of of gaining more control
so you don't want to do that you don't
want to do these terrible things you
don't you know you don't want to cheat
on your wife you don't want to okay in
fact
marriage is so wonderful because you can
give fully of yourself okay and you can
you can love your wife I'm thinking of
song of songs all right I'm thinking of
just what a wonderful thing that can be
and one way to you know even increase
that sort of Desire that you have for
your spouse
would be with a Pajamagram right now go
to pajamagram.com tell them Michael sent
you women love getting new pajamas at
Christmas time yeah I love getting new
pajamas at Christmas time everybody does
Pajamagram makes it very easy for us men
this year I cannot wait
to see sweet little Elisa in the
naturally nude line of pajamas even more
alluring than lingerie the texture and
feel of these pajamas is so silky and
smooth that both you and your wife will
love them if you have no idea what to
get your girlfriend or wife this year
trust me she wants these pajamas but you
need to order today because last year
they sold out before Christmas there's
actually one time I was trying to get
some Pajamagram pajamas and I did it too
late and they were sold out so don't do
that order today at Pajamagram
they will include a free matching
naturally nude and nighty with your
order that is 75 savings on their best
selling holiday gift pajama Graham
offers free gift packaging so your
present comes ready to put under the
tree go to pajamagram.com right now
order the naturally nude pajamas that's
pajamagram.com for naturally nude
pajamas don't forget to tell them
Michael sent you
speaking of disordered sexuality a Sam
Brinton the lipstick stiletto wearing
doggy leather
Leading Men around on a leash guy from
the Department of energy
he's been arrested and he's got a mug
shot out there and he looks a lot more
normal in the mugshot than he ever did
in his office at the department of
energy
I've got an unpopular opinion
this is unpopular so don I'm giving you
a fair warning
I feel sorry for Sam Brinton
I actually feel sorry for the guy
uh yes he's left of Lenin yes he seems
to be a huge liar yes he he seems to
have made up a lot of his biography the
center of his political biography is
that
he was subjected to conversion therapy
as a child you know that thing that
doesn't exist it was conversion therapy
and his awful parents tried to make him
not be gay or
transgender or into the leather puppy
costumes or whatever he's into and
that's what set him on his political
Journey but that story started to fall
apart because he wouldn't mention who
this evil Doctor Who tortured him was he
he then got really fuzzy on the details
and he said it actually happened in his
20s not when he was a child or a
teenager and even lgbtq Nation
obviously a left-wing publication has
admitted okay this guy's story really
doesn't check out but I really feel
sorry for Sam Brinton because he's
obviously deeply mentally ill he's
obviously got all sorts of problems and
disordered desires and that's true of a
lot of people it's no excuse necessarily
for just totally bad depraved Behavior
except for this
in the past when people had mental
illnesses and disorders and delusions
and weird desires and stuff
the culture the society
would try to help that person would try
to treat some of those illnesses would
would try to dispel some of those
delusions would try to give these people
therapy proper therapy that would say no
you're not really a woman you're a man
no you shouldn't you shouldn't drag men
around on leashes and weird leather
costumes no you don't wear lipstick boys
don't wear lipstick that's wrong unless
you're David Bowie take the lipstick off
no you no men don't wear the stiletto
heels no men you're a man and what that
means is certain things and you're
supposed to dress this way and do this
kind of thing and that's going to give
you a better life
and in our culture what happened was
exactly the opposite
in our culture
every single delusion and disorder
desire that Sam Brinton has ever had
been affirmed and celebrated by the
culture
we know who he is because he engages in
all these kinds of crazy Antics and puts
them all over social media and give us
lectures about all of his bizarre
disordered sexual desires and how much
he loves indulging them and he gets
celebrated by The Establishment media
for it and he's he's
put up as an icon of civil rights and
inclusivity I promise you had this guy
not just gotten arrested for stealing
women's clothing and Luggage he would
have been at that White House ceremony
Joe Biden probably would have mentioned
him by name
because the Administration has put him
forward as a symbol of transgender and
so I just I feel bad for the guy because
he's been abused by Society
it has been criminal neglect and
negligence that our society has engaged
in with regard to this kind with regard
to so many other people
when when the crazy purple-haired people
show up at my lectures and scream at me
about how I'm not respecting trans pans
dual Spirit rights or whatever I I have
a great deal of pity for them because
very often these are young people and
and they have been indulged
since the time they were five years old
and they've been groomed frankly by
their by their Educators in many cases
and so it's not their fault
exactly it's not their fault they're
they were raised in this way where in
the old way you'd be raised to Tamp down
your base passions and cultivate your
higher reason and your rational will
today it's exactly the opposite we're
told don't trust your higher reason
we're told that your moral conscience is
a liar we're told that the institutions
that once formed good normal flourishing
people they're all evil forget them all
you should do is indulge your your
appetites you should we should be fat
positive you should never stop eating
you should indulge gluttony you should
be sex positive you should cultivate
your lusts the weirder your lusts the
better and indulge them all the time
we're told that you should you should
give vent to all of your passions your
wrath your anger if you're if you're
feeling some kind of passion don't just
suppress it don't cultivate patience not
a spirit of resignation no no you gotta
let it out and you've especially got to
hate your parents and you've got to hate
the culture that you were raised in
because it's evil and terrible and
ultimately you should hate yourself and
you should you should not ever even
consider God as existing much less seek
a relationship with him that's all Huey
for a bunch of knuckle dragging cavemen
no no not you you're sophisticated you
just need to worship at the altar of
what the altar of our decade and culture
people have been taught this since
they're five years old is it any wonder
they turn out like Sam Brinton we got a
nation of Sam Brenton's that guy's Not
Unusual these days I mean it's it's
unusual you know we all look at him as
unusual
there was a survey that said that one in
five more than one in five Zoomers
identify as lgbtq identify as queer
Sam Brinton is increasingly becoming the
norm
and that's when something becomes the
norm that's not merely the fault of
individuals that's the fault of the
culture and of the society you want to
talk about our trashy culture there's a
new show
I'll probably watch some of it it's on
TLC it's making the rounds right now set
your cues
put it in your calendar
MILF Manor
[Music]
life has given me some curveball I think
it's my time to find love
I was married for 14 years I want to get
a chance to do me a little young men
have much more energy they think out of
the box I want that especially in the
bedroom
am in this amazing beautiful mansion
here in Mexico this is a perfect place
to find love
welcome to the Villa you're about to
embark on a dating experience like none
other oh let's go I have an extremely
high libido is that too much Shane I
have an extremely high libido should I
just said hi libido
ladies where's all the minutes
night I'm ready to connect with somebody
who doesn't really care how old I am
I'm just looking to have fun
here we go
what the hell
it just got real
this is trash TV at its absolute finest
I probably won't watch it only because I
don't subscribe to cable but if I did I
probably would watch it okay this is
really reality TV just at its absolute
Peak but it's trash it's really really
disgusting and it that last line there
is quite telling she said this just got
real
be and it did just get real and the
whole premise of the show
because these are MILFs I won't go
through the whole initialism or the
whole acronym but the first
the first letter there refers to
moms mothers and so this this is getting
kind of real because it's not just these
young people who think that they have no
consequences in their lives and they
they really don't have a lot of
accountability in their day-to-day
social life and so they go out and it's
the real world or it's the Jersey Shore
or something like that these are these
are people with children that are
supposed to have families that they're
raising that do have responsibilities to
children and they're what they're
they're on some Island in a manner
for the express purpose of
whoring around right basically they're
taking money they're being paid to go
engage in weird kind of degenerate
sexual performances with young guys on
camera that that does get kind of real
that's that's actually different from
the other TV shows that do exactly the
same thing because these are mothers
these are people that that kids are
looking up to and and it's it's deeply
scandalous more scandalous even than
other than trash TV but the other thing
that that makes MILF Manor noteworthy
and and that tells you so much about our
culture that we're living in today and
why we're even talking about it is
because the premise is absurd
young men generally speaking don't want
to sleep with older mothers generally
speaking maybe there's a few guys out
there who that's
you know negustible disputanta Mast but
generally speaking that's not real
if the show were in the reverse if the
show were older guys who leave their
wives and then sleep with younger women
that would be a normal thing it's not
I'm not saying it's a good thing but
that does happen that happens a lot
you you see a lot of couples where
there's an older guy and a younger woman
you see very very few couples where it's
an older woman and a younger guy and I
think that is part of why TLC is pushing
this sort of thing
because this is what our culture does
now
our culture subverts expectations
transgresses Norms left and right
does this
all the way at the White House with the
colors and the definition of marriage
and the way that the officials dress our
culture does this in what is taught in
the schools and the universities our
culture does this at pretty much every
turn
even in reality TV
the fact that I mean now you look at
advertisements for lingerie
advertisements for clothing it used to
be that you would have really really
physically beautiful people modeling
clothing now it's the opposite
and it's it's a political movement
they say yeah we're going to get the
most out of shape models that you ever
saw we're going to have them put it up
we're going to cultivate a cult of
ugliness I mean at every turn you see
uh wickedness substituted for goodness
our culture no longer
values goodness and virtue but quite the
opposite actually in in our popular
culture you don't see the art and TV
shows and books and movies elevating
Heroes it's always anti-heroes it's
always guys who are really bad in the
end you think of the popular age of TV
Tony Soprano Walter White Don Draper
uh Saul Goodman all I mean I could the
list goes on and on and on of all the
great it's always anti-heroes
and you see the culture elevating
ugliness over Beauty
it's probably a pretty funny TV show
because of how absurd that is but it's
it is partaking in its own little corner
of the exact same subversion and
upending of reality that you are seeing
everywhere else it is absurd
and speaking of absurdity well this is a
great example of where you see this play
out in political life we're now told
that the good guys are the criminals and
the bad guys are the cops
that's what we've been told this for
years now as the Democrats have called
to defund the police abolish the police
let the criminals off the hook it's the
criminals they're really the victims of
society and the victims of the crimes
they're really the oppressors because it
was their fault and society's fault that
the criminals turned out the way that
they did in the first place it's only
the victims are always the problem the
the criminals are not the problem and so
now the governor of Oregon is going to
commute the sentences
of people on death row Christmas is fast
approaching
it's time for all the conservative aunts
Mothers Daughters sisters to take their
place at the table
this year you are not just bringing
truth bombs okay you are bringing woke
eradicating gifts ladies
the men in your life are under constant
assault I'm going to let you in on that
secret the left is playing dirty all
right it's time to wash out the woke and
give your guys a gift that will uphold
what they believe and make them look and
smell better that would be
Jeremy's New Hair Skin and Body Care
gift bundles 100 woke free now
thirty percent off do you see what this
is
this is Jeremy's charcoal body wash do
you see what this is this is Jeremy's
shampoo do you know what shampoo I use
do you know how I get this quaff this
quaffura that I that I bring to you
every single day on the show Jeremy
shampoo that's how it's some of the best
shampoo I've ever used it's not full of
harmful gross industrial chemicals it is
extremely natural smells great it'll
just next time you're just cozying up to
your husband you give a little little
smell like your Joe Biden smelling the
back of his head you'll be smelling me
okay and many many conservative men out
there who are not giving our money to
companies who hate us they've got their
wonderful Precision five razor flip back
trimmer it's spectacular all you
conservative familial characters out
there make your presence felt and much
appreciated this Christmas go to
Jeremy's racers.com get your loved ones
some 30 off gift bundles today is your
last day to order to receive in time for
the big merry day do not wait any longer
do not wait okay this is this is a
festive time of year you know who else
is going to be celebrating this year uh
the worst criminals in the state of
Oregon the the most vicious criminals
who've who have done crimes committed
crimes that are so heinous that in Even
in our day of age which is opposed to
the death penalty they received the
death penalty
we're talking we're talking some of the
worst people walking around and the
Oregon Democrat Governor Kate Brown just
commuted all of the state's death
sentences
and she's given them life without the
possibility of parole this is to 17
inmates why did she do it
she said I have long believed that
Justice is not Advanced by taking a life
and and the state should not be in the
business of executing people even if a
terrible crime placed them in prison
that is what the libs believe now and
I'm sorry to say that's even what many
conservatives believe now sorry to say
that's even what many Catholics believe
now that and the Catholic Church always
had a very clear view on this but in
recent years some popes even and other
people in the Catholic church have
suggested that the death penalty is evil
which is just insane that's not true
that has never been the teaching of the
church going back to Saint Paul going
back to all the doctors of the church
I've mentioned this before but even
blessed Pius IX who is a pope the last
Pope uh to control the Papal States and
he's been beatified on his way to
canonization on his way to being
officially named a saint he oversaw the
executions of some 500 people in in the
Papal States so it was never considered
that uh to be in Christendom and and
throughout the West throughout even as
the West uh pulled away a little bit
from its overtly Christian
founding and animation still we we
defended capital punishment until
relatively recently
and one of the reasons why is people say
well it's not just what do you talk of
course it's just
whosoever takes the
the life of a man
who whosoever sheds the blood of a man
by man shall his blood be shed
that is Justice right and I for an eye
on a tooth for a tooth
now what's the what's the next line
after whosoever sheds the blood of Man
by Manchester blood be shed is for man
is made in the image and likeness of God
so people say well it's a contrary to
human dignity for the state to execute
criminals now on on the contrary
it is an affirmation of human dignity is
an it is an affirmation that we take so
seriously
the dignity and value of human beings as
images made in is people made in the
image and likeness of God
that if you kill someone we will kill
you back we're going to take it very
very seriously
there are three purposes to
criminal justice
deterrence Rehabilitation and
retribution
and these days we're told by bogus
social scientists that deterrence
doesn't really work no one no one
seriously believes that that's why we
still have a criminal justice system
it's why we still punish criminals but
we have to pretend based on a bunch of
bogus studies that actually know the
punishments that we don't like they
actually don't deter any crime so they
take that off the table and for
rehabilitation we say the only purpose
of Criminal Justice is Rehabilitation
and and obviously the death penalty
doesn't rehabilitate anybody so we've
got to take it off the table by the way
I think the death penalty does
rehabilitate people I think that as Dr
Johnson pointed out depend upon it sir
when a man knows he's to be hanged in a
fortnight it concentrates his mind
wonderfully I think hanging concentrates
the mind I think that actually the death
penalty can rehabilitate people in in
many cases much better than life in
prison could because they will have to
face the fact of their death they will
have to face their mortality they will
have to get right with God
so I think it has I think the death
penalty has a medicinal effect as well
but furthermore
the primary purpose of Criminal Justice
is not deterrence and it's not
Rehabilitation those can be those are
nice effects of criminal justice but
those are not the primary purpose
the primary purpose is retribution the
primary purpose is punishment
it's the only way to justify putting
people in prison or killing them
it's the only way to justify it because
you can deter people from committing
crimes
by killing all sorts of people in in
ways that might not be just that might
not be proportionate okay to just deter
a crime if you just had a a crazy
tyrannical regime that engaged in a
reign of terror that would probably
keep people in line pretty well you
probably wouldn't even raise an eyebrow
at the regime if they were just lopping
off the heads of anyone who opposed them
that would deter people but it wouldn't
be very just
what about Rehabilitation well if
Rehabilitation were the primary purpose
of prison and capital punishment well
then you and I would probably end up in
prison at any given time we could all
use a little Rehabilitation
I'm not holier than now I'm not
absolutely perfect
could use a little but I haven't
committed a crime and therefore it would
be unjust for me to go to prison
retribution that is the primary purpose
of prison and criminal justice and
capital punishment
you you go there you have to you you
face these punishments because you have
committed a crime
and certain crimes are so heinous that
human dignity strongly recommends the
use of capital punishment because the
state the Civil Authority does not wield
The Sword in vain but today we're so
morally idiotic that we can't think
about that
when was the last time that you heard a
prominent politician say the purpose of
Criminal Justice is
to punish people for committing crimes
it's not just Rehabilitation it's not no
that's completely lost even among the
people who should know better
so much for human dignity
okay well now we're saying that the the
rights and the values that we have
they're all secular values anyway when
the president of the United States is
saying that the allegedly devout
Catholic President of the United States
was in any wonder that the rest of us
are confused too speaking of dignity
one of the least dignified displays I
have ever seen occurred yesterday this
was this is so pathetic I almost didn't
want to play this on the show because it
just it makes me feel ashamed to be a
republican makes me feel ashamed to be a
man okay it makes me feel ashamed
John Boehner
the former Republican Speaker of the
House
appeared yesterday at the Capitol is
broadcast on C-Span to pay tribute
to Democrat
soon to be former speaker Nancy Pelosi
and he didn't just do it as a
perfunctory well you know we disagreed
on things but you served your country
and uh this guy was blubbering he was
crying about and this the the former
Republican leader in the house just
blubbering about how much he admires
Nancy Pelosi
Madam speaker I have to say my girls
told me
tell the speaker
how much we admire her
except they couldn't tell my girls were
Democrats
it's all the spirit I just talked just
Nancy I love you so much Nancy
that was the Republican leader
is it any wonder why Donald Trump got
elected in 2016 is any wonder why
Republicans conservatives just despise
the Republican party because that's who
they are
the Republicans get elected so that they
can go to to Washington DC and pretend
to put up a fight and then at all the
crucial moments to squish and to concede
and to give the Democrats what they want
but they'll pretend they'll give the
appearance of opposition they're they
get elected so that they can go be Court
Jesters in the Kingdom of liberalism
there have been all these rumors for
years I'm not telling Tales out of
school it's been in all the newspapers
that John Boehner
likes to take a dram every now and again
you know or more specifically red wine
you know he's uh can toss them back and
uh a lot of people say that the reason
that he cries and blubbers all the time
is because of that I don't know I don't
have any particular evidence that John
Boehner is an alcoholic and I I actually
don't want to spread that rumor or
anything because I just don't know in a
way I almost sort of hope that he is
because it would explain this Behavior
more so than if he were absolutely Stone
Cold Sober all the time say well
something is even more wrong here about
that but regardless we we can see John
Boehner
cannot control himself he can't control
his emotions John Boehner famously cries
in public all the time and this is
supposed to be endearing according to
especially the liberal media but it's
not it's sad it's not dignified don't do
it
now we're now we're told real men cry
all the time and they whine and they cry
and they're actually women but no you
shouldn't you shouldn't do that
you're going to cry from time to time do
it on your own time do it in a corner
don't
you got to act like a man you got to be
able to control yourself you've got to
be able to control all of your base
passions and emotions and Reign them in
okay maybe you're a glutton maybe you're
lustful maybe you're a wrathful maybe
you're blubbering maybe whatever
keep it together ma'am keep it together
a great example of this is Jay Leno
jail you know Jay Leno just lit his face
on fire and now he's telling jokes about
it we don't have time to get to this
these are great though there's a
wonderful Jay Leno story that'll be the
the uh
hook that'll be the Cliffhanger that I'm
leaving you with on this public portion
of the show because now we've got to get
to the member block we've got an amazing
interview
a 14 year old girl needs a kidney
transplant
this 14 year old girl is being denied
the kidney transplant by Duke Medical
because she won't take
the covid vaccine the vaccine
that we now know is not nearly as safe
as they told us it was the vaccine that
we now know is not nearly as effective
as we told us as they told us that it
was the vaccine that we now know does
not really do all that much to for
younger people
well it does certain things to younger
people but none of them seem very good
this the the doctors at Duke Medical
seem prepared to let a 14 year old girl
die
because you can't get a kidney
transplant rather than let her receive
the kidney transplant without getting
the experimental drug that Dr fauci's
been peddling we will be speaking to at
young girl's mother
rest of the show continues now you do
not want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]